disturbing canvases of bloodletting and
guts anish kapoor's latest work isn't
for the faint-hearted i don't see it as
gory weirdly i think it's it's it's um
opening up what we all carry within us
clearly
at one level death is here
um
but
i hope so is beginning
since winning the turner prize in 1991
he has become one of the most prominent
contemporary british artists who made
headlines with his polarizing olympic
park commission
more often known for his sculptures but
kapoor has always painted now at modern
oxford seeing the two presented
alongside each other
the artist takes audiences to a very
primal place bloody and brutal and
almost like a human sacrifice
we must dare
and i think as artists it is our job to
dare
um and to risk it it's a risk you know
people may love it or hate it what can i
do the wonderful thing about painting is
that you just do it so
do it it's all about doing it and i
paint with a stick rather than than
with a brush
an outspoken critic of the government in
its decision to cut arts funding right
now the artist is angry
educating our children to be fodder for
the capitalist machine
how dare they how how outrageous
it's a right-wing agenda that we have to
resist with all our energy
kapoor says the art world has to find a
way to resist capitalism quoting picasso
anish says art is war
and is that what we've got here
i hope so i hope it's war
yes
so not nice little things that you are
feel comfortable with i hope bloody
uncomfortable things
confrontational work from aneesh kapoor
coming at a time when he sees the art
world as under attack katie spencer sky
news